laser screwdriver whoo - sonic so this
is the video that I alluded to that I've
been meaning to get around a long time
and that is I am finally going to rank
the masters now I rank the doctors and
the Companions years ago like so long
ago that I'm starting to consider
revisiting and REE ranking them adding
in the newer folks who've come along
since I last did those things um but I'm
not setting any promises for when that's
going to happen but I'm well overdue to
rank the masters and when I found out
that John Simm was coming back for the
end of series 10 and that it was going
to be the closeout for Missy it felt
like this is the time to rank the
masters now I am restricting this to
appearances in the show I was obviously
both classic era and modern Doctor Who
I'm not factoring in Big Finish stuff or
anything like that so that gives me
eight and I'm going to say it right now
I'm not counting the stand-in who is at
the very beginning of the Doctor Who
movie from the 90s so forget about that
and we'll start right at the bottom and
since I brought up the Doctor Who movie
from the 90s occupying the bottom spot
at number eight Eric Roberts happy bad
for Eric Roberts not like in uh-oh you
can find a way he didn't do a great job
but the reason I feel bad and I think he
probably had no idea who the master was
or what he was like and was probably
relying entirely on whatever the
director told him and he actually kind
of feel that across that entire movie
like the only thing that feels like
Doctor Who is the doctor himself Paul
McGann who did know Doctor Who and was
aware of this character and the legacy
and the importance of this and it feels
like nobody else involved everything did
but in any case getting back to Eric
Roberts he actually feels like he's
playing two different characters at
different points in the movie starting
out he almost feels like he's trying to
terminator he's got this odd stilted
almost robotic way of speaking and and
then later on he hits the pen he gets
the full outfit and just those I just
Wow
dude really entertain you just he can't
take him seriously at that point and
they give a period in the middle between
the really robotic and the really
flamboyant where he's kind of okay but
he never really works because they
botched the intro
he's just boring and then at the end you
take you can't you can't take that
seriously you just can't he doesn't work
moving on number seven
Peter Pratt now Peter Pratt played the
master in the deadly assassin which is a
very good doctor whose story and the
master is very well conceived and very
well used in that story I'm still
putting this performance way down at the
bottom though and again can't completely
blame the actor different reason this
time this time the problem is the mask
because who that thing and you know
looking at still image of it doesn't
really do it justice and when I say that
I mean you look at this dilemma to go
hey that's kind of cool and as a still
image it is but when you see it in the
show and you realize those I never move
and never blink they realize that Mouse
doesn't really move but moves just
enough to give away the fact that it
should be moving more than it does and
he's and he's trying to act through this
mask that is basically just completely
blocking him and it's muffling his
dialogue not like to the point of bein
voice but you can hear him like really
forcing his voice to try and come
through this thing and it still sounds
muffled and I don't think anybody was
going to make that mask work if I'm
being completely honest and if I set the
the handicap that that mask gives a side
he's fine it's not really wrong with his
performance he's not really called upon
to do all that much um but he's fine but
that he's not good enough to make up for
much of a detriment that locked-off
unblinking thing is it's and
unfortunately because it levels his
voice even though they show the face not
very often you can still hear her it
still it still feels like a mask as you
is he sounds like a person trying to
talk through a mask doesn't work number
six
Anthony Ainley I wished I could have put
him higher up on this list but I can't
and with a clear conscience because he
he was the master for quite a while and
he's not awful but he's missing a really
key element and that is Menace he never
really feels particularly threatening
part of us performance part of that is
also the writing because the master have
been around for a long time at that
point and the writers kept bringing him
back but kind of didn't know what to do
with him at that point and that he and
he suffered the problem that any
recurring villain who can't be permitted
to win has which is that eventually they
just become a buffoon because they just
keep showing up and failing again and
again and again and again and again and
that was happening to the master during
Anthony and Lee's tenure to the point
that they had to introduce a new evil
Time Lord with the Rodney to try and
make up at the back of the master nobody
could take him seriously anymore he's
best when he first shows up he's pretty
good in Lagavulin and castro Velva but
even there like it's not quite working
again he got sort of the Glee in evil
but I get he's just lacking the Menace
he's lacking the threat um and also just
all of a sudden doesn't doesn't make
sense
like as a plot as a scheme a little
accomplice is always one that that
jumped out at me because like at the
very end and I'm not going to recount
exactly this works but like he's like
out of nowhere decides he's got to hold
the whole universe hostage and force
every civilization to appoint him their
ruler and it just it kind of happens on
an oar and it's a plan that makes no
sense like on so many levels and it's
funny it's something that I'm actually I
actually handled better now because of
stuff that's happened in new who you
know when they establish you know the
drums that is headed that he is crazy
not just in a in a you know the hero
tells him you're mad you're insane but
like legitimately insane I can now look
back at these are these things and go
well of course he came up with an idea
that kind of dull Mendoza really work he
had drugs in his head but that wasn't
the case of time it was just kind of not
great writing and a performance that
yeah he feels he feels like how the
master would be in the Saturday morning
cartoon adaptation of Doctor Who just
slightly softened will move along number
five John Simm now John Simm I you can
really break down as a parents very
easily into three segment you had his
appearance at the end of series three at
the end of the specials in the end of
time and at the end of series ten and
everyone is very distinct and I can even
work within within his listing I can
rank those appearances very easily
access top at the end of time in the
middle of series ten at the bottom in
series three
that's for me I know other people really
prefer how he first was when he first
showed up in Series three for me is it
he's too manic and and I know that
sounds weird for me to say because I
said I enjoyed the fact that he's
legitimately crazy but he was a bit to
sort of bouncy waki ah I'm not a killer
people kind of thing and it was weird
and it felt inconsistent with who the
master is because who the master is has
felt much more rigid than who the doctor
is because the doctor former generation
to generation has kind of been free to
shake it up a bit more now that's not to
say that you can't shake it up from one
more generation to the next with the
master but it just that that sort of
adding that to his personality it just
seemed too immature and again it kind of
cartoonish you wuzzle and i get the idea
behind it because
he was it was like she was matching the
energy of David Tennant vo who was a bit
more bouncy and everything so I guess
the theory behind it it really didn't
work for me that said I really do like
his second appearance I really do like
him in the end of time and I like him
because he is legitimately cracking up
and coming apart and I think Johnson
played that very well and I get a lot
more of that menace and the threat from
him when I know that it's not just a
matter of him coming up with an evil
plan but he's so unstable that he could
just turn on a dime and just decide out
of nowhere that he is going to do
something that's even worse than like
some sort of crazy scheme would be and
that's kind of what happens over the
course of that story and like I said I
like that so much that I can look back
on earlier appearances that maybe seem a
bit wonky and remind myself he's kind of
crazy and it makes it a little bit
better that's how much I like this
aspect to the character at the point
that it was introduced and Johnson
playing it it's just really good and
because there's also that sense of
desperation to him because he knows he's
coming apart he knows he's dying
and that for me was his best work and
his work in series same kind of falls in
the middle I think he was kind of under
used as a presence but um it's good it's
it's solid there's a there's a little
bit more of the Menace to him but he has
just just a little bit of the start it
balance much better so like if his
appearance in series 3 have been more in
line with how he appeared in series 10
honestly he might be higher on the list
but I have I he really doesn't work for
me in series 3 and that is dragging him
down on this list so let's move up from
here we get into the upper half with
number 4 Jeffery beavers now as I said
I'm only taking the show into account
here I am NOT taking Big Finish audio
into account and if I were he might rank
higher but I haven't heard a lot of Big
Finish audio yet it is stuff I want to
get around to but I'm not going to put
this list on hold while I catch up on
that so Jeffery beavers in the show has
one appearance as the master and the
keeper of trackin effectively playing
the same version that Peter Pratt played
but doing it with a mask that actually
allowed him to act because he had his
own eyes that have moved with his mouth
and he was able to just deliver a
performance as opposed to just be a
muffled voice behind a mask and he's
really good a bit like my favorite
turned that John Simm did there's a
desperation to him and there's a feeling
that his desperation because he knows
he's running out of time and his body is
falling apart there's a feeling that
that desperation makes him more
dangerous and Jeffrey B versus sells
that really well in a fairly limited
amount of screen time in only one story
and it has made it so that I when I get
around to more Big Finish stuff I want
to prioritize some of his appearances as
the master in those because I think he's
really really good he delivered a
performance that felt true to the
character and felt like it was it was
pushing it forward at the same time and
for a guy who just came in for a one-off
gig props to him seriously and that
brings me to number three another guy
who was a one-off in the gig Derek
Jacobi now he was actually the master
proper for a pretty short amount of time
if I'm being fair and I try not to count
his his work as jana too much in his
ranking but I have to a little bit
because the contrast of how sort of
sweet and affable he was as Yana do then
just turn on it and I literally turn
like that turned to camera there is more
menace and there is more
oh my god we're in so much trouble just
rule you can read in his face in that
one turn the camera then most actors who
play the master manage in any part of
their time in the part he just you look
at that you go we are
rune and his wine delivery is a little
arch in Jersey I am the mascot but it's
just again I think largely because it's
compared to just how sweet he was before
it feels like he is he feels it's almost
like he needs to overcompensate how evil
he is to make up for the fact that he
was sweet of you seconds ago and if I
really really wish we could have gotten
some time with him as the master
legitimately there was a time when I
just wish he hadn't regenerated into
John Simm at all and that derek jacobi
hadn't been the master um through that
entire story because i like john sims ii
variance in the end of the time so much
i don't feel that way anymore i do feel
that ultimately was it was worth it to
have John Simm but for a while I kind of
would have happily Chuck John Simm out
the window to get more Derek Jack to me
he's really good so we're up to the top
two and obviously we lose some tension
because if you know who's played the
master then you know who's less they
want to say number two that also means
you know my number one but we're going
to take the time star on number two
properly anyway before we speed through
number two Michelle Gomez as Missy I
love Missy I love almost everything
about Missy I love how playful she is
and yet she's unpredictable she always
feels dangerous and while she doesn't
necessarily have that same sense of
menace I talked about she does and she
manages to still feel threatening and
not in a you know intimidating I would
kill you way but you never feel safe
around her and I think that was really
well established when she killed Oswin
because up to that point when she first
showed up she was sort of light and
playful you're like this this
incarnation of the masses kind of fun
and and then she killed oz with who was
the character I think fans had
immediately embraced and had loved and
it it was a harsh you know slap across
the face don't get comfortable with her
she is dangerous and Michelle Gomez
never lost that edge from there on and
here's the other thing and this is a
really big thing that these last two
have I think over the others and that is
chemistry with the doctor she was
opposite to she and Capaldi have such
good chemistry
not only as villains but his friends and
I've always loved that aspect and
because and that was another part of
especially Anthony Ainley that really
didn't work as you've lost the sense
that he used to be the Masters friend
and you lost that sense of the doctor
wishing that he could bring him back and
you got that with missing and and the
twelfth doctor and the they're they are
so good together and they sell the idea
that maybe she is coming around and yet
it never felt like a cop-out because she
kept like sliding by eating when she's
trying to be good she's still being kind
of a jerk about it she's still kind of
almost going about goodness in an evil
way if that makes sense
is like it's like her line has gone from
chaotic evil to lawful evil or something
it's just it's fascinating and it's just
so much fun to watch it I'm really sorry
we're not going to be getting any more
of her but if you know your masters you
know the actors who played them then you
already know my number one Roger Delgado
the first the original the best and I do
honestly think Roger Delgado is the best
he just immediately epitomizes
everything that the master should be he
is charismatic he is menacing he is swab
he is diabolical
and he has such good chemistry with Jon
Pertwee as the third doctor and that
really is a big key and again you do get
that feeling when they when they
interact with each other that sense from
both of them that slight sense of I wish
we didn't have to fight and
that just combined with Delgado owning
this role I mean there's a reason they
kept coming back to the master and that
is because he landed it so perfectly
right out of the gate and you know his
chemistry with Jon Pertwee in such that
he personally himself said that Delgado
death an unexpected death by car crash
was part of what led him to decide to
leave the show because he had been back
and forth on the idea up to that point
but once that happens like I I really
liked working with him I can't keep
doing this without him and you get to
have when they're when they're in scenes
together and even episodes that aren't
great because not every episode he was
in was great but whenever the two of
them are screened together
it's electric the matter really was
conceived as the Moriarty to the doctor
Sherlock Holmes and you you you feel
that template very much in Delgado's
performance but it works
it's just spot-on it works they nailed
it at the gate and even though there
have been other masters some of whom I
love I don't think there's ever going to
be one quite as perfect as Roger Delgado
and so that is my ranking for the
different performers who have played the
master on Doctor Who
what is your ranking for the Masters or
do you just want to slag me off and tell
me I'm an idiot because I put this
person up higher this person down low
whatever you want to do drop something
down into comments let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter a council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]